the shortest month is wrapping up and
that means March is just around the
corner with another batch of free games
with gold if you're an Xbox Live Gold
member and want to know what you can
grab for free I've got you covered
first up on Xbox one is Batman the enemy
within the sequel to tell tales
narrative Batman adventure as you make
choices that change the story you'll
encounter classic villains like the
Riddler bane Mr Freeze and Harley Quinn
you've got time to make those decisions
as Batman will be available to download
all month long
speaking of Heroes Xbox one's other game
is Shantae half-genie hero this
platformer stars Shantae herself who can
whip enemies with her hair and transform
into various animals each with their own
abilities you can also replay stages in
hard mode or go for a top speed run time
in hero mode Shantae will be available
for March 16th through April 15th on the
360 side you can dive into castlevania
lords of Shadow 2 this particular entry
actually has you play as Dracula as he
fights the only thing worse than himself
Satan yah hits pretty hardcore the
game's open world spans both medieval
and modern times and you can explore
both by downloading the game for March
1st through the 15th back to the
light-hearted stuff the 360s other game
is Sonic Generations
this particular Sonic game sees you
controlling two different hedgehogs
classic sonic runs across side-scrolling
stages while modern sonic dashes through
3d levels you can go twice as fast by
downloading Sonic from March 16th
through the 31st and thanks to backwards
compatibility both this and Castlevania
can be played on Xbox one as well and
those are your free games with gold for
March 2020 remember that you can always
check out gameplay clips and reviews for
these titles on GameSpot and stay tuned
as we report on the new games with gold
lineup every month
[Music]